welcome everybody and thank you for
coming to our talk my name is Adam and
today my colleague magic and I will be
talking about the project we're both
part of called coming safai so what do
we mean by comics if I as some of the
smarter people in the crowd might have
guessed it has something to do with
comics more specifically we developed a
tool to transform videos into comics
surely one of those grander problems
humanity has yet to solve so to quickly
to quickly get you up to speed we will
start with a short application demo
[Music]
which is deployed and you can try it out
yourself you can upload your own video
use youtube link or try out one of our
samples you can enjoy the video in while
the demo is processing and here are the
results so we get our comics and back to
the presentation successfully okay so
you can you can visit the demo at comix
if i dot e to try it out your stuff on
your own videos and experiment with it
okay so so to reiterate our application
takes videos as input and outputs full
fledged comics and at the end we split
our application into two main parts
keyframe extraction and style transform
much we'll be talking about a style
transfer and I will be covering keyframe
extraction and it's it's a part I'm
mainly involved with so keep from
extraction so what is a goal what is the
goal of keyframe extraction in this
scenario as you all know I guess at the
beginning video consists of thousands of
frames and as you have seen from the
demo at the end we use only ten of them
so keep from extraction part is goal is
to go from thousands to only a few Oh
before we show our solutions we want to
to ask ourselves a question
and what frames are we looking for for
comics we surely want our frames to be
representative so so they tell a full
story correct story of the video we also
want our frames to be diverse so so that
they cover the full feature space of the
video and it's we also want our frames
to be of good quality we don't want to
have any artifacts and delivery images
as we need to remember them later on in
style transfer all the defects in the
images will be amplified so based on
these three principles we have built our
pipeline so first step is video sampling
so working with each frame of the video
is computationally expensive and
unnecessary we have found that first
down sampling the video was two frames
per second we don't lose a lot of
context and well yes we don't lose a lot
of context or action with two frames per
second we still have a lot of frames so
we need to further move them down
further before we proceed to the next
step we do some feature extraction and
we use Google Annette first version we
trained okay now onto our first model
next step is summary score we use a
model from video summarization task what
is video simulation video summarization
is a task of producing short and concise
summaries of videos which is sounds
pretty similar to what we're trying to
do here we use one of the solution
one of the best solutions for this task
currently it's a at the core it's a be
directional SEM network and it's a
reinforcement learning model so as you
can see it takes frame features and
produces a score from 0 to 1 for each
frame that shows the the likelihood of
this frame to be included in the summary
that summary is like then
rewarded with a function so basically
for some learning I want to give you
some more intuition about their world
function it's one of the main parts of
this approach so in our case in this
case author used a combination of
diversity reward function and
representing as the move the reward
function so the diversity reward
function measures the dissimilarity of
frames in feature space so we compare
selected frames pairwise and we want
them to be as similar as possible and
representativeness function we formulate
the degree of representativeness of a
selected summary as as I came into this
problem so we want our selected frames
to be we want our selected metal centers
to be okay we select metal centers we
want our other frames to be asked arrow
between other friends and our centers to
be minimal so we get our summary score
so it's a score from 0 to 1 you can see
on this graph the x axis is a frame
number and y axis is the score so we can
really use this core by itself and we
can just select the frames with the
highest score it will it will produce
and not very good results
that's why we have our next step a
temporal segmentation so we have our
scores and - yes to preserve some
diversity when we first segment the
video into segments using kernel the
broad segmentation algorithm as you
might have in front from the title it's
based on broad differences between
frames so after segmenting our video we
calculate an average summary score for
each segment and then we rank our
segments so we sort them from top to
bottom and then we select from each from
top 20 segments in our case one frame
with highest summary score that's how we
get our 20 frames both still too much
and as we as in some cases we have found
that the results of this step produced
blurry and generally not good images and
we wanted to battle that with our next
step and which is Nemo you must stands
for neural image adjustment it's a it's
a model developed by Google which
basically assess the quality of images
as you can see on the slide at the top
the input image represents the input to
the model and the scored underneath is
the now we can clearly see that images
with higher scores look better so to
talk a little bit about architecture of
this model they basically took a basic
baseline image classifier Network and
removed the last year layer replaced and
retrained in a in a very smart way the
network based on their image image
quality data set yes
so we have our 20 frames we produced
initially
we score them with NEMA and then we
select pairwise ten frames from the 20
so we compare first and second and
select one of them one of them and with
this we we have our final ten frames
which which later on proceeded to start
transfer part about which magic we'll
talk in more detail okay so let's go to
the second part of our presentation
which is style transfer our course was
to have solution that will work in real
times so we wanted to process those ten
frames in about 3 1 to 3 seconds the
second goal was to get good quality with
sharp listenings edges and uniform and
vivid colors and the third goal was to
have no distortions and well content
preservation in their final images so
for such example images we would like to
have something like this in a perfectly
real solution now the brief brief
introduction to the neural style
transfer the first work about style
transfer was introduced two years ago
SVP our conference it was created by
young Gatti's and his coworkers and they
mostly focus on artistic style transfers
of the Thai style transfer of some
paintings to style of paintings to some
images and it has one disadvantage men
main disadvantage which was time
processing so the processing time of
this method was about for casual image
was about two to three minutes on some
modern GPUs how it worked they use
classical vgg 19 architecture which is a
convolutional network that has five
conversion blocks and it was the part of
witchetty that they used so they didn't
use the remaining fully connecting
layers and they define the process of
site transfer as optimization process
they define the cost function
the sum over content and style the
content is just future maps obtained
from the passing the content image and
why it's nice image and future amounts
are obtained from some port block and
it's just miss Qin era and this type
part is much more interesting because
here we have weighted sum over some
mineral losses and each of their
minerals minor losses is just mean
squared error between gram matrices
obtained from these losses gram matrix
is matrix that describes all
dependencies between all pair of the
vectors and in our case vector is just a
vector eyes feature map so after a few a
box of training this stuff
with stochastic gradient descent and
backward propagation I mean but we
propagate those gradients to values of
this of the white-noise image pixels and
after fill a box we will have results if
you look more or less like this yes but
it is very slow unfortunately after
after this initial work there are much
more different papers concerning style
transfer one of this world were
real-time style transfer the
architecture here is pretty similar to
this that we saw here I mean that loss
network is pretty similar but they
introduced also the second Network which
is style transfer network
so here during training we do not
propagate gradients in directly to the
white-noise image but we propagate them
to the weights of the style transfer
network and after a few of you view a
box of training outer cells that is
about two days to train such a framework
we will have a style transfer network
that will output the image in a style of
this one image and with preserve content
this of this image and this solution
works in real time it's about 100
milliseconds for processing cover casual
image
it has one disadvantage I mean there is
only one network for one style so if we
want to have many styles then we will
have we'll have to train a lot of
different networks and also another
disadvantages is the fact that here we
style is still defined by one image and
we believe that comic style transfer
cannot be described only by one image
there were a lot of more into
improvements in this beautiful transfer
for example arbitrary state transfer and
universal state transfer they are still
very fast and they give you opportunity
to use many different styles with one
network here we have some results of
those methods how arbitrary style
transfer works it is pretty similar to
the real time standard style transfer
but with two differences the first
difference is the fact that here we have
also a style image as an input to this
style transfer network and the second
difference is the fact that we have a
dine layer between encoder and decoder
in the style transfer network what is a
dine lair it is just a layer that
matches simple statistics of feature
Maps obtained from the content image to
match statistics of feature maps
obtained from the style image a bar and
buy matching statistics I mean only
matching the variants of feature maps
and matching mean of those feature maps
Universal transfer is very similar to
arbitrary transfer but here instead of a
dine layer we have a W City layer which
which stands for whitening and coloring
transform so instead of matching simple
statistics we match Hall covariance
matrices matrices of feature maps
obtained from the content image to match
feature Maps obtained from the
assignment and also we have four levels
of utilization so the output of this the
biggest network is an input another one
and so on and so on we tested all of
those approaches and some combinations
between of
in terms of how they handle the
comic-style transfer but unfortunately
we found that all of this all of them
suffer of a lot of flaws and there were
some inappropriate color transforms
there were a lot of distortions and they
still only use one style image
fertilization and we would like to have
a solution that will take an input as an
image and produce the comics without
having to without necessity to give them
some station image and that is why we
switch to so called generative
adversarial networks
guns is a framework on the set of two
networks the discriminator in the
generator where the generator is trained
to create images that will pull the
discriminator and discriminator is
trained to classifies whether an image
is from the real distribution on or from
the fake distribution produced by
generator and they share the same cost
function which we will be called calling
minimax loss function and the
discriminator tries to minimize it
whereas the generator tries to maximize
it and to be more precise it tries to
minimize the negative version of waste
but in this year on the cvpr conference
there was a very beautiful paper called
carton gun generally for personal
networks for photo carton ization and
outers proposed solution that was pretty
pretty what we wanted to have in our
application how it worked they define
the year gun framework very similar to
this basic framework as I described in
the previous slide but with few
differences the first difference is the
fact that they use instead of only
minimax laws they also use the content
laws which is pretty similar to the laws
that I showed you in the initial gutted
work so it's just mean squared error
between feature maps obtained from
certain layer from GGG Bijlee and the
second difference so and it of course
penalized the fact that
wanted to have semantic content
preserved as an isn't in an output of
generator and the second thing is the
second difference is the fact that here
instead of having only two bunch of
images the real distributions which are
cartoon images and fake distributions
that are generated cartoon images we
have also a third class which are carton
images with blurred edges and why do we
need this third batch of images edges
are a very small part of image and they
at the same time are very important for
comics and as well for cartoons
so we've and without having this this
additional but probably our generator
will not be able to learn how to
synthesize those comics properly and how
they were created it's just they're just
carton images we've blurred edges using
some Gaussian smoothing in the originals
of detected edges and edge detecting
cause you created by just using
can hear detector yes and we implemented
our discarding gun oh they also
introduced one more thing they pre
trained before actual training of the
whole framework they also pretend the
generator to output the images the same
as an input and they thought that this
will speed up the training significantly
we trained our over our own version of
this carton gun
framework but unfortunately our results
were not satisfied this Factory and they
we've all very often stacking were
stacking some local minimis and results
were quite poor so we introduced two
changes the first change was to use
instead of using minimax loss we use the
non saturating clause and why is that so
if we shared the same minimax loss for
generator and for discriminator
then if the discriminator is very sure
about distinguishes images from the real
distributions and from the fake
distribution so we are here it's about
to zero then the cost function for
generator and for discriminator is also
very close to zero then also gradients
are very close to zero and generator is
not able to learn anything more and if
we introduce no saturating clause which
is the green curve on this chart for
generator then if our discriminator
discriminator will be very sure about
distinguish is this in images then our
generator will be still able to learn
something and it will not stuck in some
local minima so easily it it really
worked another thing was to pre-trained
also a discriminator not only the
generator before actual training so we
I need to distinguish images from comic
images from content from those blur
address and another addition was to use
the generator discriminator ratio in
training
so for discriminator we update weights
on each of those free batches I mean the
comic images with blurred edges [ __ ] its
first batch the second batteries will
comics the third batch is are those
generated minutes and then after we
perform three updates on weights of
generator instead of using only one data
we use different keyframes obtained from
cartoons scrapped from the web we want
we only use cartoons with distinct edges
and uniform colors which was it is what
we wanted to achieve in our final
solution and here are our results so for
such images our result is in the top
right corner and those bottom ones are
results from carton gun framework a
shared bar filtered by authors of this
paper
as we can see oil solution preserved
content preserves content very well
edges are very clear and distinct and to
be also obtained some very uniform and
vivid colors and let's get back to our
key frames so we stuck them in some
layout and apply comics if occasion
actually we apply comics if occasion big
for the stacking the layout but it just
like that looks more beautiful in the
presentation and this are results of
carton gun and the comparison in our
version which is on the Left we have
much more sharp images and which is our
advantage and sometimes we have
sometimes it's too much too much
photorealistic but we have no distortion
so it has pros and cons and in further
works we'd like to we would like to
focus on two things the first thing is
to use dynamic layout generation so the
size number shape and arrangement of
keyframes we would like to have based on
import and their importance and we would
like to also have them in some kind of
way visually I pleasant and we also
would like to extract dialogues and and
put them in some speech bubbles in
proper frames so Final Solution we would
like to have to look like this after
comics if occasion and more or less like
this after using these speech bubbles
and this is pretty and without our
presentation we would like to also thank
our home home home members whole team of
the research team and also Google for
granting has some Google platform
credits for that enabled us the
development and deployment our project
and we strongly encourage you to visit
our page and connect safai your own
video
and that's all thank you very much any
questions regarding Comics comic
certification alright are you coming to
one question yes what took you the most
time to develop out of those all of
those modules what was the most tiring
and troublesome training our own comics
gun was a very very time-consuming we
caught with because we tried a lot of
different different combinations of
parameters and different architectures
and and to get final final solution so
it was the most difficult part from my
side from my side well initial research
and probably implementation of the
models and their combination how big was
a team actually four people people okay
so and how long have you worked on that
how long have you worked on that we've
been working about five months on it
okay and the first three months was more
it's mostly research and too much was
the development do you plan to extend it
somehow
yes describe complex generation and I
mean layout generation and and maybe
this extraction cool all right thank you
so much for coming here I hope you're
going to be able to join the after party
and have some like different discussions
with fellow friends so about please